follow me because this is your backstage
pass
mackenzie falls has nothing on the real
teen drama that went on behind the
scenes of
sunny with a chance demi lovato was only
a teen when she started the hit sketch
show
the pressure of being overworked and in
front of the camera pushed her to seek
treatment for her mental health
but demi wasn't the only one unhappy
another cast member quit hollywood for
good after the series wrapped
plus we'll discuss the constant name
changes cancelled spin-offs and
almost made fourth season that had this
disney channel show
drenched in drama from the start that's
what i thought that there was something
wrong with me little did i know that
there was a chemical imbalance in my
brain
on april 25th demi and almost the entire
cast of sunny with a chance
opened up about their experience working
on the disney channel comedy during a
virtual reunion
while sunny might have given us plenty
of reasons to laugh
life behind the scenes wasn't nearly so
fun demi announced that she'd be leaving
the show in 2011
after its second season i am not ashamed
and i have nothing to hide
that's my girl she was just 18 and
recently completed treatment for
physical and emotional issues according
to the official statement
i was dealing with bipolar depression
and it was very severe and i didn't know
what was wrong with me but wanting to be
away from the cameras went a lot deeper
than that
at the time she told people magazine
being in front of the camera would make
me nervous
sunny definitely wasn't the start of
demi's issues with mental health but she
does
think the show contributed to a steady
decline that left her needing space away
from the spotlight which is hard to find
when you're a woman on tv
during the reunion demi opened up to
tiffany thornton who played the
glamorous
tawny about her inspiration to come back
to show business
you were my biggest inspiration coming
out of it because
you dealt with all of those pressures of
being a woman
on tv young demi sometimes hated what
life was like on the set of a hit tv
show
i was so miserable and like angry too
because i felt like i was being
overworked which i was
at the time of production she wouldn't
even have a lunch break to herself
instead they'd be filled with meetings
at night she'd write song after
song and work on upcoming projects and
then be so nervous for the next day
she'd barely sleep disney liked to keep
it under wraps just how hard their young
stars would work
therefore i ended up self-medicating and
coping with very unhealthy behaviors
but demi also had some wise words for
anyone just starting out in show
business
looking towards the future because
that's what i do when i'm struggling or
when i'm going through a rough time i
look towards the future for hope
demi's dressing room on the sunny set
used to be freezing cold
and it had everything to do with the
eating disorder she was dealing with
during filming while many seemed to know
about her struggles with food at the
time
demi didn't get much help until she
finally went away for treatment
during filming her negative feelings
towards her body just grew because she
was trying on a new wardrobe all the
time
her and tiffany both opened up about how
picky they would get with their wardrobe
and how judgmental they would be towards
themselves
every time they looked in a mirror in
the years since sunny demi has been very
vocal about the eating disorder she
suffered as a child star
and a lot of her advocacy focuses on
body positivity
i don't really deal with body shamers
anymore because i don't look at it
it's pretty obvious that so random was a
quickly developed idea to continue the
sunny series with demi's absence
but the truth behind the spin-off is
actually pretty sad
so random was created as an easy way for
disney to keep programming while also
letting everyone in the show keep their
jobs
hey guys sterling knight here check me
out on so random on the disney channel
but its primary purpose was as a sort of
break from the series that would
hopefully pick up
in just a year or two the spin-off only
lasted one season
and didn't really address sonny monroe's
exit from the cast
because they were hoping demi would come
back and they would continue
as usual the show would have likely
gotten a fourth season if she'd agreed
to return
but by the time she was done with
treatment demi wasn't interested in
feeling overworked again
it's worth mentioning though that there
were no hard feelings between the cast
members after they split
but it definitely complicated things for
the disney channel
there was a time where i really resented
the people that bullied me in my life
did you know that tani and sunny are the
only two characters from sunny with a
chance who appear in every single
episode
while a lot of people assumed there
might be some female rivalry behind the
scenes
demi put that to rest in the reunion by
talking about how much she admired her
older co-star
she even served as a bridesmaid at her
wedding and caught the bouquet
but being on sunny came with a lot of
pressure for tiffany thornton too
she decided not to continue a career in
acting and instead moved to texas to
start a family not long after the show
wrapped
i still wake up every morning and pinch
myself and can't believe that i do
what i love to do for a living tiffany
also mentioned tawny's fave lip shade
coco moco coco during the reunion and
dropped some major truth the shade was
never real and tiffany actually hates
brown lip colors
this one isn't so much a dark secret but
it definitely represents the darkest
timeline
did you know that we almost didn't get
to see sterling knight as the one and
only
chad dylan cooper sometimes i heard you
get to have that
perfect dance with that one special
person sterling didn't even audition for
the role of chad but instead for some
character named stuart
stewart got cut and sterling eventually
got put into the role of chad
who was also supposed to have a
love-hate relationship with tawny of all
people
thankfully once the crew saw their
chemistry and how good they were at
being rivals the relationship settled on
mostly hate
while chad dylan cooper might have
radiated confidence sterling himself was
dealing with some self-esteem issues
during filming like most of the young
stars
thankfully he chose to stick with acting
though he did just narrowly miss out on
getting his own disney channel show
it's exciting to be here it's always
nice to come back and and see everyone
and you know
yep that's right mackenzie falls could
have been its own spin-off team drama at
disney and we're crushed that we'll
never get to see it
the show was based off dawson's creek
and the lead star's name poked some
friendly fun at chad michael murray
just like so random was meant to be kind
of a saturday night live for kids
mackenzie falls was so popular among
fans that it very nearly made it into
its own show
which might have been a huge hit on the
disney channel still doing mackenzie
falls and you get to see
chad kind of let his guard down and be
ridiculous sadly everything that had to
do with sunny got scrapped after so
random ended
so mackenzie falls will remain that
cheesy teen drama that could have been
speaking of alternate sunny with the
chance timelines there was originally
supposed to be a love triangle between
sunny
chad and get this nico we can't imagine
the pair being anything but friends
but the complicated on-screen
relationships went away backstage where
all the castmates were actually pretty
good friends
one hidden cast mate was ortho a vampire
puppet that they used to put in each
other's dressing rooms as a prank
once brandon michael smith who plays
nico tried to scare tiffany backstage
and he got punched in the face for it
but hey she warned him she didn't like
being scared i don't like being scared
and i come out like fighting like i'm
not a fan of that
creators of sunny with a chance had a
big identity crisis trying to come up
with the show
the concept took a while to create it's
a show within a show after all
so they had a lot of interesting naming
ideas before the show finally kicked off
first it was supposed to be called
sketch pad which would have also been
the new name for so random
two other names floated were welcome to
mollywood and welcome to hollywood
because sonny's name was supposed to be
either molly or holly
the idea for sunny actually kind of came
out of nowhere i'm sunny i'm new
obviously otherwise you would have
knocked finally for the darkest
what if did you know that bridget
mendler was almost sunny monroe
the good luck charlie star auditioned
and almost got the part but was just
barely beat out by demi
if she had gotten it we wonder if she
still would have starred in good luck
charlie
and what about demi it's hard to say if
her future would be better or not
without sunny with a chance
but the actress is thankful for the bond
she built with her co-stars and for the
experience that taught her to really
listen to
and take care of herself and while we
love bridget we can't imagine sunny as
anyone
else do you wish we'd gotten a fourth
season of sunny with a chance
or what about a mckenzie falls spin-off
let us know your favorite sunny what ifs
in the comments section below
don't forget to hit that like button and
subscribe to the things for more great
videos
thanks for watching and see you next
time
you